for all cause mortality cardiovascular
disease and total cancer there was a
roughly j shaped association
such that doing some amount of
resistance training was associated with
lower risk
for those outcomes but
past a certain point
continuing to do more resistance
training was associated with elevated
risk so
are there increased
risks of all-cause mortality
cardiovascular disease and cancer if
you're doing more than two two and a
half hours of resistance training per
week
it would be nice to just be able to
dismiss that out of hand and say yeah
this must be a spurious correlation we
know resistance training is good for you
there's no way that this could
possibly be indicative of possibly like
an underlying causal relationship
but i i do think it's worth taking
seriously but i think it's also worth
contextualizing so
in cohort studies that are looking at
all calls mortality
they're primarily using cohorts of older
adults
uh which makes sense you know if if
you're interested in the association
between
some behavior lifestyle factor and dying
and you want to be able to reliably
detect that effect or association
you need a fair number of people to die
in your study between enrollment and
follow-up and you don't get that if
you're studying 20 30 year olds so
most of these studies use older adults
and so uh you know here here is a
potential explanatory chain i'm not
saying this is for sure what's happening
but i do think it's at least plausible
so
you know it could be that for older
adults people in their 60s and 70s um
you know
with with everyone doing resistance
training there is some level of training
stress
that you can uh
adapt to productively you put stress on
your body your body adapts to it you
come back bigger stronger than ever
things are good and then there's a level
of stress past which you can't
productively adapt to anymore uh and you
know the the nomenclature typically
given to that is over training but
basically you're just putting more
stress on your body than it can cope
with and instead of getting stronger and
more robust it starts breaking down bad
stuff happens
and so it's entirely possible that with
older adults
the point past which training tips over
from being productive to unproductive
and potentially deleterious it could be
like a pretty reasonable amount of
training so not five six hours a week
but maybe two two and a half hours per
week um
so you know older adults already have
higher baseline levels of oxidative
damage inflammation
it could be that once they're doing more
than two two and a half hours of
resistance training per week again on
average like i'm sure it varies person
to person but on average two two and a
half hours of resistance training per
week that may be more than their body
can can cope with and adapt to
and instead of having a
overtime net reduction in inflammation
and oxidative stress maybe it's causing
net increases which might accelerate the
overall aging process
leading to
increases in all-cause mortality and and
non-communicable chronic disease risk
that i'm not saying that is for sure
what's happening but that is at least
one plausible explanation for these
findings that i think is worth
considering and taking seriously however
there are
alternate explanations so one
uh is just that um resistance training
causally like with pretty much any dose
up to some high threshold uh resistance
training does causally reduce your risk
of all of those things
but it could be that the individuals
included in these cohort studies who
were doing a lot of resistance training
differed from the rest of the cohort in
systematic ways so for example
maybe you get some sort of serious
diagnosis or just some blood work comes
back that looks really really bad and
the doctor says like hey man like you
need to get in shape or bad stuff's
gonna happen and so you know
you say hey my time is running out i
need to do what i can to prolong it i'm
just going to start working out like a
madman to try to prolong my time on this
earth and so you have
maybe a group of people who were already
in generally poor health doing a lot
more resistance training on average than
maybe people who were doing less
resistance training but were overall in
generally better health and maybe the
resistance training is reducing the risk
in the people who were already at high
risk but they still die at higher rates
just because they were previously in
poor health like again i'm not saying
that is for sure what's happening but
that is another potential explanation